hey everyone dogan here and this is the
the new office the first video in the
new office it's amazing i've been
getting a lot of questions about the
house the number one question being why
are the ceilings so low in certain
places and i'd like to go to the
transition space between my office my
studio and the rest of the house in
order to answer that now so the reason
that they're so low in some spaces is
because when you go through an area with
the low ceiling it makes the areas
without the the low ceilings with the
high ceilings
feel
way more spacious than they actually are
99 of the time that i'm in here i'm just
walking from this door into my office
you know i've got like a little desk
here that i can maybe do some work at
and uh you know i put some more like my
japanese books up here but i would never
be standing in this area for more than
two or three minutes and when i go
through a space like this that feels a
little bit intentionally cramped
then
when i go into the office
which has this much higher ceiling this
ceiling feels
way higher than it actually is this is
actually a
design kind of cue from traditional
japanese architecture the way that i
understand it is that older japanese
houses i think it might have been the
chests the tea rooms they would have
these very very low uh windows well very
low doors such that samoday samurai
couldn't easily get into the room
while holding their swords you have to
duck through
and get in it's kind of a security
measure and as a byproduct of that what
would happen is when you
when you were crouching down and then
look and once you finally got through
that and into the room it made the room
feel
way bigger than it actually was and so
this again my understanding of it kind
of became a staple of japanese
architecture in well traditional
japanese architecture in certain places
make certain places that you aren't in
for a long time
feel a little bit cramped a little bit
maybe cozy to use a euphemism such that
when you get to the the where you're
going the room that you are in for a
long time it feels way bigger than it
actually is now there is one exception
to this kind of low ceiling you're only
in the place with a low ceiling for a
limited period of time and that's this
room this is the guest room the reason
that the ceilings are so low in here is
actually it's a building regulation so
if the ceilings are any higher the space
gets treated as a room but if they're
under a certain height then the space
gets treated as
a monoki kind of like a kind of like a
storage space or just kind of like a
maybe that kind of like an attic is the
best way to think about it
and in keeping the the ceilings low in
here we were able to stay within the
laws that dictate
how
the the overall total surface area of
a house in japan because this is a guest
room because it's it's meant to be a
place that people are mostly just
sleeping i imagine when you know i'm
filming a video with mr yabadan or you
know like chris or any of my other
youtube buddies that come out and stay
here we're going to be filming you know
down in the big room
we're going to be filming in my office
we're going to be filming it in
different areas out in the courtyard and
then this room again is mostly just for
coming up at night and sleeping so
that's when the ceilings are the way
that they are in certain areas of the
house i know it's definitely not for
everyone but when i saw the same
architectural principles being applied
at the the model house and heard the
explanation i thought it was really cool
and i wanted to try and do something
similar here and i'm really happy with
how it turned out going to be making a
lot more videos about the house in the
near future about the cost of materials
etc if you have any questions feel free
to leave a comment below alright talk to
you guys soon
[Music]
you